okay so maybe 2020 wasn't the greatest
year for hollywood blockbusters but the
good news
is the future's looking bright from firm
franchise
favorites to the most exciting new
projects here are the must-watch movies
of the next few years
thanks to the ongoing kova 19 pandemic
in 2020 marvel studios had their first
year without a theatrical release in a
very
very long time that's okay though
because 2021 promises to be an
especially robust year for marvel's
superheroes
and it all kicks off in may with the
long-awaited black widow
since her character didn't survive the
events of avengers endgame natasha
romanov's solo adventure will take her
back in time
to the period between captain america
civil war and avengers infinity war
after the breakup of the avengers black
widow is called back home to untangle
conspiracy with roots in her own past
though she's venturing out on this
adventure without any of her fellow
avengers
natasha will be joined by a team of some
of her old russian friends
including her sister in arms elena her
mentor molina and
the former russian super soldier known
as the red guardian
originally slated to arrive in may 2020
black widow will now roll out a year
later
on may 7 2021 after years of rumors
suggesting that his time as james bond
would be coming to a close
it's now been confirmed that the 25th
james bond film
no time to die will mark the curtain
call for daniel craig
though he's made fewer films than
previous title holder roger moore
craig has now been the reigning bond for
a longer period of time than
any other actor by the time no time to
die hits theaters he'll have spent a
decade and a half in the role
the name's bond james bond
it's fitting then that he seems to be
going out with a very big bang indeed
director kerry fukunaga helms the latest
bond adventure which sees craig's double
07 facing off against the sinister new
villain
known as saffin no time to die was
originally set for a november 2020
release but was pushed back a number of
times
due to the covet 19 pandemic it's now
slated for an april 2021 release
there have been two films in the
kingsman series so far and they've both
focused on largely the same cast of
characters
but that's set to change in 2021 when
the franchise goes back to where it all
began
the king's man a prequel film once again
helmed by original kingsman director
matthew vaughn will venture back to the
early 20th century
finding a different set of kingsman
agents as they try to stop a team of
criminal masterminds from wiping out
millions of lives since the movie is set
a hundred years ago you probably
shouldn't expect to see eggsy or harry
show up but the cast led by ray fines
and gemma arterton is pretty dazzling
nonetheless
the film was originally set to arrive in
november 2019
then was pushed to february 2020 and
then again to september 2020.
things took a turn for the worse when
the kova 19 pandemic hit forcing
another schedule shift the film is now
set to finally hit theaters on february
12
2021 frank herbert's hugely influential
sci-fi novel dune
has already been adapted to the screen
twice once for the big screen by david
lynch and once for the small in a sci-fi
mini-series
both versions have their fans but 2020
was supposed to bring a dune adaptation
like no other a big budget ultra
ambitious epic helmed by genre luminary
and blade runner 2049 director denis
villeneuve
sadly the covet 19 pandemic means dune
fans will have to wait a little longer
to see whether vilnev has pulled it off
or not but that doesn't make it any less
exciting the first trailer for dune was
packed full of astonishing visuals
setting a truly beautiful stage for this
story
of a doomed family and the hostile
planet they make their home
dune was originally set to be released
during the 2020 holiday season
but ongoing pandemic concerns meant that
the release date has shifted
the movie will now arrive in theaters
and on hbo max
on october 1st 2021 it's been more than
20 years since the last film in the
candyman series
but in 2021 that's set to change with
director nia decosta's sequel to the
original urban legend driven classic
set long after the first movie's creepy
housing projects have been torn down
the film follows visual artist anthony
as he moves into the now gentrified
complex with his girlfriend
and begins an art project digging into
the local folklore
what begins as an intriguing idea soon
turns into a nightmare however as he
discovers the legend of the candyman
is frighteningly real candyman was
originally set to be released in june
2020
pandemic induced delays pushed into the
fall of the same year however
and then delayed the movie again to its
current release date of august 27
2021 on july 9 2021
marvel will release shang chi and the
legend of the ten rings
a superhero epic with a kung fu edge
chinese canadian actor simulii
has landed the title role of marvel's
master of kung fu in the film
which will also star aquafina in an as
yet undisclosed role
but aside from being marvel's first
asian-led mcu movie perhaps the most
exciting thing about shang chi
is the villain 2010's iron man 3 seemed
to introduce the classic comic villain
known as the mandarin only to then
reveal he was simply an actor
playing a role as part of another
villain's evil ploy
just a role the mandarin see it's not
real
but the mcu later hinted that the real
mandarin is still
out there and now it seems his time has
come
the genuine mandarin will make his mcu
debut in shanghai
as played by the legendary hong kong
actor tony young
every once in a while disney will take a
couple of bankable stars
throw a bunch of money at them and send
them on a crazy stand-alone adventure
and sometimes it even works out based on
the disney theme park ride of the same
name
jungle cruise pairs dwayne the rock
johnson alongside
emily blunt as they set out on an
adventure into the heart of the jungle
searching for the mythical tree of life
the commuters joe may call it sarah
takes directing duties on the film
which was originally set to be released
on july 24
2020 for reasons that should be obvious
at this point the film was delayed and
is now due to hit theaters on july 30th
2021 in 2018 the halloween franchise
returned to the silver screen
in a big way featuring the return of
jamie lee curtis as lori strode
the movie ignored every previous sequel
to john carpenter's 1978 original
setting the scene for a showdown between
strode and michael myers that was
four decades in the making but as it
turns out
it wasn't their last in july 2019
carpenter and curtis announced that two
more sequels are coming
chronicling the continued struggles of
lori strode and her family
against the specter of the shape curtis
will return
of course as will the previous movie's
director david gordon-green the two
sequels were originally set to arrive
one year apart
in october of 2020 and 21 but like so
many other releases
they fell victim to a reshuffling the
first sequel
halloween kills will now land in
theaters on october 15th
2021 the second halloween ends
hasn't been given a firm release date
having being bumped from 2021 by its
predecessor
whenever it does arrive however you can
expect that final movie to provide a
fitting end to the tale of lori strode
it's been a long road already for the
uncharted movie
and unfortunately it seems like the road
just keeps getting longer
active development on a film based on
the hit game series can be traced back
to at least 2010
and over the course of a decade the
project has seen a number of writers and
directors come and go
the movie finally landed on venom's
ruben fleischer's director
and will star tom holland as a younger
version of the video game series hero
nathan drake uncharted is set to explore
drake's early days as a treasure hunter
and will co-star mark wahlberg as the
young adventurer's partner victor
sullivan
in january 2020 deadline reported that
sony pictures had bumped the film from
its previous release date of december 18
2020 to march 5th 2021. there was still
one more delay in store however when
industry reshuffling in the wake of the
coronavirus pandemic saw uncharted push
to july 16
2021 in 2018 mgm decided it was time to
bring the beloved video game franchise
tomb raider back to the big screen
with a new take that hewed closer to the
more recent installments of the game
series starring alicia vikander as lara
croft the film dove into croft's first
treasure hunt as she followed in the
footsteps of her father
tomb raider grossed 275 million dollars
worldwide which proved
more than enough to set development of a
sequel in motion vikander will return to
her starring role as lara croft and
called genre director ben wheatley will
sit in the director's chair the
screenplay has been written by
wheatley's longtime partner amy jump who
co-wrote the director's other films
including highrise and free fire
tomb raider 2 was first slated for
release on march 19
2021 but has now been delayed
indefinitely
as a result of the pandemic for more
than a decade dwayne johnson has been
pushing for the development of a
superhero movie that sits particularly
close to his heart
and soon he'll finally make his big
screen super debut
starring in the movie of the same name
johnson will play black adam
a character first introduced as a
villain for the superhero now known as
shazam
adam had previously wielded shazam's
powers but was corrupted into villainy
before long however the character was
later retconned to be more of an
anti-hero
adam was originally supposed to be a
villain in the first shazam movie but
johnson's commitment to the role and his
view of adam as a heroic misunderstood
figure worn out
and the character will now be getting
his very own movie black adam is
currently awaiting a new release date
after being bumped from its originally
scheduled release of december 22
2021. all of you around the world right
now watching i can promise you this i
give you my word
that we are gonna go beyond your wildest
expectations in late 2018 and early 2019
warner brothers did a lot of work to try
and inject some fun into the dc
extended universe that effort began with
aquaman which was a massive box office
hit over the 2018 holiday season and
continued with shazam which arrived in
early 2019 and proved
equally successful with fans and critics
the movie never quite reached the box
office heights of aquaman but it still
hauled in a decent 366 million dollars
worldwide
then in late 2019 warner brothers
announced that a shazam
sequel is on the way zachary levi is set
to return in the film's title role with
director david f sandberg
also set to return behind the camera in
2020 the title was revealed to be shazam
fury of the gods there's no word yet on
exactly what the plot will be but the
original film set up
plenty of opportunities for new foes
including the potential introduction
of black adam after his own film drops
fury of the gods is expected to arrive
on june 2nd
2023 ask any
long time star wars fan what kind of
movie they'd like to see outside the
main saga
and there's a good chance you'll hear
the words rogue squadron the legendary
band of starfighter pilots was a major
part of the old star wars expanded
universe and now it seems set to be part
of the new one
disney announced in december 2020 that
wonder woman director patty jenkins will
helm a rogue squadron feature film
and that it will be the next theatrical
release in the star wars universe
in a short video introducing the project
jenkins described the movie
as the fulfillment of a lifelong dream
to make an amazing fighter pilot movie
in honor of her father who is a fighter
pilot himself
now i found a movie about two things i
love so i'm gonna see you very soon
plot details are scarce but we do know
that the film will focus on
a new generation of pilots in a future
era of the star wars galaxy
more will become clear in the run-up to
rogue squadron's release which has been
slated for december 2023
acclaimed writer director tycho attitude
already has something of a history with
star wars
after finding considerable success at
marvel studios with thor ragnarok
yt joined the group of directors
recruited by john favreau to helm the
first season of the star wars
live-action series the mandalorian
in which he also voiced the bounty
hunter turned nanny droid
ig-11 ytd must have made an impression
on the lucasfilm crew
because in may 2020 the official star
wars website announced that the director
has signed on to make a new
star wars movie details on the project
are still extremely scarce however
and nobody has any idea what it'll be
called when it'll be set
which characters are involved or even
when it's supposed to be released
all anyone can be sure of is that
waititi is working on a
star wars movie but hey that's good
enough for now
the earliest rumblings around disney's
purchase of fox
immediately sent waves of anticipation
through the marvel fandom
by the time the deal was done geeks
everywhere were champing at the bit for
any news about the future of fox's two
biggest marvel properties
the x-men and the fantastic four mostly
however kevin feige
and company kept a tight lid on things
then came disney's investor day
presentation in december 2020 when feige
announced that a fantastic four movie
is on the horizon very little is known
about the movie
but it has been announced that
spider-man director john watts will be
at the helm
aside from that anything could happen
though they first felt more like a
relatively minor part of the wider mcu
narrative
the ant-man movies have since become a
kind of cornerstone for the future of
the franchise
mostly thanks to scotland's major role
in avengers end game
now the third adventure for the ant-man
crew is on the horizon and
ironically enough it's said to be a big
one marvel announced in december 2020
that the third feature in the series
will be titled ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania and that it's set to
introduce one of the biggest villains in
the marvel universe
the time-hopping warlord kang the
conqueror
lovecraft country star jonathan magers
is set to portray kang
making him one of two major mcu
newcomers in the film so far
the other being freaky star katherine
newton as scott lang's grown-up daughter
cassie
ant-man and the wasps stars paul rudd
evangeline lily michael douglas and
michelle pfeiffer are all set to return
for the film
as is director peyton reed the film does
not yet have a firm release date
captain marvel was a game changer for
the mcu when it debuted
in 2019 it was the first female-led
marvel studios superhero film
it introduced the skrulls to the
franchise while expanding the role of
the cree
and it set the stage for more super
heroines to join the mcu
so captain marvel 2 was always going to
be a big deal and now we're starting to
get a sense of just how important it
will be
mia decosta is set to direct the second
solo adventure for the title character
but this time carol danvers
won't be fighting alone she'll be joined
by tiana paris as monica rambo
a grown-up version of the character who
debuted in the first movie
and who in the comics is currently known
as spectrum joining the two of them will
be iman valani as kamala khan
aka miss marvel a captain marvel
superfan
turned superhero who's about to debut in
her own original series on disney plus
captain marvel 2 is set to hit theaters
on november 11th
2022 not too long ago it seemed
unthinkable that there'd be any more
installments in the toy story series
then toy story 4 came along and wrapped
an even tighter bow on the franchise
now it looks like toy story is moving on
in a way that nobody could possibly have
predicted
in december 2020 disney announced that
pixar animation studios has been hard at
work on
light year a new animated adventure
starring chris evans is the voice of the
title character
presenting a kind of origin story for
everyone's favorite space ranger
but as evan's later clarified via
twitter this isn't the story of the toy
in fact this is the story of the real
buzz lightyear
the character who inspired the toy
that's an intriguing idea and we'll see
how it plays out when lightyear hits
theaters june 17th
2022 marvel studios has been eager to
produce a sequel to black panther ever
since the first film
rocketed to massive commercial and
critical success
in 2018. unfortunately in 2020 hollywood
was rocked by the tragic passing of
chadwick boseman
bozeman's death left a number of
lingering questions from black panther
fans and in december 2020
marvel started answering a few of them
during disney's investor day
presentation
kevin feige announced that black panther
2 would still be moving forward
under the leadership of director ryan
coogler but that the role of t'challa
won't be recast instead feige told fans
to expect a movie that both honors
bozeman's memory
and continues to explore the world of
wakanda however it takes shape
black panther 2 is set to hit theaters
july 8 2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you